[Music]
what's going on guys reboots remakes
sequels part two three four the Cineplex
a--'s are lousy with them our original
ideas dead or are they just sleeping
we're gonna talk about that very idea
today and we've got a pretty cool couple
of folks to talk about it with first oh
she's been with us many times you know
her from sj+ and Fandango indie movie
guide Alicia Malone hey thanks having me
oh thanks for uh thanks for stopping by
and this fella right here Mark Ellis
super funny stand-up comedian and he's
one of YouTube's schmoes no and if you
are in New York for New York Comic Con
October 6th at the New York Comedy Club
see this man lay down some stand-up
comedy that's right how all the jokes I
will be doing that night are gonna be
sequels or reboots of previous jokes
that I have already performed let's look
at some raw data here okay
fact checkers get ready okay of the 50
top movies in 2016 so far only 12 are
original properties by contrast let's
compare that to the year 2000 16 years
ago 31 of the top 50 movies were
original properties and stories what's
changed
that's what people are going to see I
mean Hollywood will follow where the
money is so things like Avengers did
really well the box office they're going
to make more of that and these days
Studios can't afford to take any risks
they don't want to make any original
films that might not do well they want
to make something that that can really
be a franchise opportunity something
that can see them through the long term
because there's just not that much you
know because I have to compete with all
the other forms of entertainment these
days yeah with the new millennium that
was the dawn of the Golden Age if you
want of the cinematic universes in comic
book movies so now instead of having one
x-men movie that comes out every so
often now you have multiple films from
each one of these universes that are
coming out every year and if you're just
a kid that's mowing the lawns to make
some money that summer where you can
only go see a couple movies that year
that's probably what you're going to be
spending your money on it from a
business perspective it people's jobs
are on the line here so if you need to
make a movie and it's got to be a hit
you're gonna dial up what has
earth in the past there were a lot of
franchises this summer that had big
opening weekends but then didn't have
legs do you feel like there's some
fatigue
I mean superhero fatigue and/or
franchise fatigue oh I think what's
happening is because the studios aren't
taking risks and because they have to
fit within the cinematic universes
directors aren't able to give something
original and new and different feels
like every movies been made by a
committee so it's all very safe it's all
very you know it's standard and
directors have to fit in with other
directors previous work or where the
franchise is going next and so there's
just not that level of originality so I
feel like audiences are picking up on
that so they'll go to see the movie
because the marketing is great they want
to be part of the conversation and then
word-of-mouth will get through that it's
actually not that great and there won't
be that repeat viewing you're the people
who are on the fence and then you have
these cautionary tales like josh trank
was trying to make a risky original
version of the Fantastic Four and then
the studio pounced on it tore it apart
brought in a pod as well felt like it
was muddled because other people got
involved it's interesting to see this
past summer like even a movie that
critically wasn't a huge success like
Suicide Squad did have legs at the box
office and I think a lot of that is
because people want to see these kind of
properties they want to see particularly
DC Universe have a nice rebound after
Batman V Superman there's the nostalgia
as well of people who read comic books
when they were young or people who loved
Point Break when they were young or
whatever it is that they want to go back
and see it not so much Ben Hur yeah
right particular towards the end of the
summer I think we all started to feel
that fatigue whether it was sequel
fatigue or superhero fatigue because the
end of July we had bad moms come out
nobody really expected that to do much
that thing hung around the top five in
the top ten and to its credit I laughed
a lot watching that movie something like
don't breathe there's something even
like Kubb on the two-streams which might
even based on previous source material
but it felt original and fresh and I
think audiences glommed onto that yeah
you mentioned don't breathe and Kubo
animation and indie horror are two
places where we're getting a lot of
original voices that we haven't heard
from let's take a look at the top ten
movies this year
barring sequels
and remakes etc okay so number one the
secret life of pets Wow okay I'm just
learning this it's that's how it grows
Zootopia that's surprising to me it's
crushing I mean it came down the middle
of summer I think that I think a lot of
people love Zootopia and so we wanted to
see another movie like Zootopia so they
saw secret life of pets and it was such
a great concept that really helps sell
the movie then Central Intelligence Bad
moms as you said a couple of original
comedies they're an animated comedy
sausage party
don't breathe lights-out got our indie
horror right there the boss Melissa
McCarthy the shallows Blake Lively and
the shark and then Mike and Dave need
wedding dates are there any kind of
patterns we can suss out there well I've
interested with the indie horror stuff
because I think Blum House has done such
a great model of this micro budget movie
so they turn out 40 movies a year but
because they make them for such small
money it doesn't matter if they don't do
well the ones that hit they hit so well
then it makes up for it so we're
interesting what's happening with indie
horror and then animation is still going
strong
here's another thought the original
movies topped the box office from 1980
to the year 2010 times and in recent
years it's fallen off drastically you
rarely see an original movie winning the
year one of the outliers their avatar
but now you see how many avatars are
lined up so that's following right along
the sequel train it's almost like
they're bastardizing their own mythology
because we're gonna keep going to
Pandora we're gonna take every natural
resource out of that planet until we're
done telling stories there but when that
movie came out it was such a
technological revolution I think it's an
important point to bring up in this
conversation is that people wanted to go
to the movie theater to see avatar
because you heard it was such an
incredible experience people want to go
to the movie theater to see something
like Star Wars or Captain America civil
or a Batman V Superman because it's a
theatrical event and you don't
necessarily need to be in a giant movie
theater to enjoy something like hell or
high water even though it might be the
best movie out of everything we're
talking about it can be easily
digestible at home as well whereas if
you're watching a huge superhero movie
at home you feel like they're out on
something I know you've both been to a
lot of cons and film festivals you just
came back from a couple
right Alicia what's the market like
there the hustle to try to get
distribution for an indie film it's so
much hustle so much networking and you
see people at these film festivals
hustling for both their movie that's
already made and then for their movie
that they want to get made and it's it's
a hard hustle I don't think people
realize there's definitely so many
original movies out there then in the
indie world but the hustle to get them
even made in the first place is getting
tougher and tougher along with
everything else in the film industry
it's not like there aren't indie films
right like you mentioned hell or high
water another one I just saw recently
don't think twice there's so many good
little movies out don't hear about them
because they don't have the budget to
market these films I like the superhero
ones day and they disappear so fast so
we it seems like uh maybe we've been
pooh-poohing the larger movies a little
bit but there's a lot of good ones I
don't want to don't get me wrong
Mad Max fury road Deadpool the Planet of
the Apes films Deadpool I mean that took
so many risks and that felt wholly
original even though it was part of
technically of the cinematic universe
Deadpool was a passion project a 700
million dollar box office earning
passion and I love that pose all my
favorite movies of the year but here's
the scary thing to think about from a
studio perspective is they see Deadpool
opening in some weekend in February
going that big doing oh well now we can
open a comic book movies in February and
we should all write it comic-book movies
because that one did well what's
happening now is that we're studio C the
entire year you can release a big-budget
movie it squeezes out some of the middle
class of film or the lower class of film
that don't have the budgets to promote
their movies and go up against the big
guy you used to be you only have to
worry about the summer being blockbuster
month and then maybe the holiday season
now it almost feels like year-round
there's going to be a huge movie coming
out every weekend yeah ok so we've
talked about the past we've talked about
the present state what do you see
happening going forward taking into
account maybe a little bit of sequel
fatigue etc I'd love to hear from both
of you what do you see going forward the
foreign film market now is really
important China is going to overtake
America very soon as being the most
important box-office
in terms of money in the world as soon
as they let in more American films and
what plays well their action movies 3d
IMAX and then things that they've heard
of before war-cry warcraft is a great
example it didn't do well here but
didn't matter it made a lot of money in
China I'm hopeful that things will
change and equalize back to the way they
were and more of those middle budget
dramas and just quiet movies will get
made but I think it's going to take a
long time because people are still
paying to see these films and they're
still making money and then with the
foreign markets like China seeing the
films I think actually as Hollywood's
attention will shift towards making
films for other markets and not just
America yeah it's going to be
interesting to see the way that you can
make a buck making films going forward
if it's going to continue to be the old
model of your movie has to be released
in a movie theater and popcorn sales
that's why popcorn cost $10 is because
so much that goes back to the studio but
maybe that changes in the near future
with all these ways we have to ingest
new content you can just open up your
computer you can turn on your TV and see
brand-new films if that continues to
happen there might be a huge seismic
shift in the way that it's processed
both from a studio perspective and from
people watching it at home also I think
something that influences it and there's
no way to predict this you need those
visionary authors to come along like
your Paul Thomas Anderson's your
alejandro and your Ritu's christopher
nolan's whoever to create that content
that is exciting and fresh like a
memento or like a Boogie Nights I saw
denis villeneuve arrival I want to see
right over and it was so good and that
has a sizable budget and completely
original Wow so there are a couple of
voters like that now one last thing I
want you to look into the camera and
tell Hollywood what they need to do what
do you think Hollywood needs to do
Hollywood if you're listening please
trust your directors you hire them for a
reason they have a voice they have a
vision don't muddle up the movies just
trust them I like it Marc Hollywood
listen to Alicia below more I think we
should all listen to Alicia Malone more
it was my pleasure listening to Lisa
Malone and it was your pleasure as
well do you think there's sequel fatigue
is their superhero fatigue or do you
love the climate of movies that we live
in let us know in the comments section
below
I want to know what you think I gotta
thank Alicia thank you for coming back
great friend of the show and Mark Ellis
check them out in New York City on
October 6th and check them out on the
schmoes and thanks again mark and thank
you for watching I'm Hal Rudnick hit me
up on Twitter bye bye hey guys did you
know that this end card works with your
phone now I know right click the boxes
below to watch more screen junkies
videos and click the screen junkies logo
to subscribe and get this show honest
trailers movie fights and more